Hello everybody!
Skate aboard here.
Today we are back with more Tamatachi live.
Uh, yes, I know originally.
Oh, look at her go.
I might time travel because I'm tired of playing at night.
I want to know what it's like in the day.
We might travel back in time because I just want to know
what it's like during the day.
Uh, does it affect?
I don't know.
I feel like daytime has different stuff.
going on versus nighttime so i feel like oh my god look at
her go that's right get your reps in um so skater skaterbird
here uh but anyway uh what i was gonna say oh yes uh the
reason why we swapped games is i found out i didn't realize
but apparently the bow wow game where you're a dog you go
thank god uh i was actually gonna set up some more noise
canceling stuff for today but uh now i have less work to do
But basically, the reason why, because the reason why we're
not playing it today, and we pivot to Tomodachi Life, was
that apparently, majority of the game is made with AI,
apparently, and I wasn't aware about it, because all I saw
was, I saw a lot of Twitter accounts, a lot of social media,
a lot of viral Japanese tweets talking about the game, and
I've been, like, following that game in terms of, like, I
never opened the Steam page, so I didn't realize it was...
You know, there's like a disclaimer at the very bottom where
it says like, oh, it's made with AI.
Like, like this is made with AI.
And then it's like, I didn't open the Steam page.
I just saw a lot of funny clips about it.
And how, and it was like super, yeah, it's like super viral
right now in Japan with big Japanese streamers.
I know like a lot of big VTubers in Japan as well as big
Flesh Tubers in Japan have been streaming the game.
And it went into my algorithm.
And I was just like, they put a disclaimer?
Well, it's mandatory.
It's a mandatory thing.
So you have to disclose that it's made up with AI.
And I tend to, you know how me, I forget to read that
disclaimer.
And I haven't opened the Steam page yet to check it out.
I just thought, oh, look at all these big streamers playing
it.
It looks really fun.
I didn't realize.
The majority of the artwork and the music is made with AI.
So I was like, oh, shit, I didn't realize it.
So that's why we're pivoting to Tomodachi life.
I didn't realize it.
So now that I know, now I know.
I opened up the Steam page today and I was like, oh, well,
okay.
So I apologize for not reading.
reading about like reading the steam page for it uh i'm not
used to reading steam page with the disclosure and stuff
because usually usually i can tell but i couldn't tell maybe
i was just tired i just saw the clips maybe i just saw the
fun the clips i was like that looks really funny and then i
i it didn't click in my head that the artwork was um was ai
um also like i'm not used to reading the uh the steam page
for like ai disclosure for in games because you know how ai
in video games is sort of like a newer thing so it's like a
newer thing um and i'm glad that steam has a disclosure for
it like it forces people to forces the devs to disclose if
something is made with ai uh but it's still like a new i
guess like a new phenomenon where it's not like page whether
or not it's disclosed but i'll definitely do it more in the
future for sure uh but like i said like yeah i i uh i just
saw it being super viral so like in my head i was like oh
it's so viral like um and no one like it's so viral and it
seems really funny so that's why like in my head i was like
oh i it it didn't seem like ai to me at first uh patro esu
thank you the super chat thank you thank you please read
doki valentine thank you with super chat thank you thank you
No apologies needed.
I bet more than half of us dragons, especially me, had no
idea.
It was made with so much AI.
I mean, thank you for sparing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Vial equals should be.
Well, it was more so like a lot of really, really big
streamers were playing it.
Like big corporate VTubers were playing it.
But it was only most like big corporate VTubers were playing
it.
Big like million, million followers, streamers in Japan were
playing it.
head that like there was any like there was anything bad
with the game so and there was a lot of like there were
clips yeah there were clips that had like uh millions of
views on the game and i was like oh that's really funny it's
like so you're just it's basically the game was like you're
competing against another person um it's a fun it's
basically like the premise is funny it's just sad that they
because i think the game would have done really really well
if they didn't use ai stuff for it because the premise
itself was really good they could have literally drawn stick
figures and i think people would have still played it
because it's such a funny like it's just a funny mechanic
where you're just you and another person just scream at each
other and be like and whoever barks the loudest wins and
it's such a fucking funny mechanic but it's just unfortunate
that they used ai for all of it for majority of it it's it's
just a it's called bow wow um uh yeah it's the it's the dog
barking game the bow wow game so you just play as a dog and
go yeah um maybe yeah uh so that's why we're pivoting the
tomodachi life oh yeah speaking of ai uh i i heard about the
other controversy and i was like oh Thank God I was too busy
to do that sponsor.
That was the other sponsor that my manager rejected because
he was like, you're too busy to record another song.
And I was just like, you're right.
So I was like, whoosh, dodge the bullet there.
I'm not involved in that.
What happened?
Nothing.
Nothing happened.
I went by doing nothing at all.
Went by doing nothing.
What else?
I'm sure your neighbors are so glad.
Yeah, I think my neighbors are really happy.
that i swap games on the dog thank you with the super chat
thank you thank you what else what else oh yeah dad update
um i've been trying to take dad more to the dog part lately
to socialize more um and um um you know yesterday two days
ago it was a success like he had a great time well he didn't
he's so antisocial he's he doesn't like interacting with
other dogs he only likes is like his dog like his unless the
other dog is a weaner dog like same dog same dog but he
doesn't give a fuck about other dogs anyway so I was like
two days ago I was just like oh nice he you know didn't
fucking try to bite any of the dogs or didn't try to
intimidate the other dogs that's progress so I took him so
cuz usually I put him on a leash lately because like he's
been getting more he's been getting like pretty brady and
aggressive so like he keeps intimidating other dogs so i've
been putting him on a leash whenever i take him to the dog
park because i don't trust him and then so yesterday i was
just like you know what no leash you had a good you made
good progress two days ago no leash time so he's getting
racist as he gets older that is life um anyway so um like
one of there was a golden retriever and he was like fine
with him like more so like he didn't give a fuck about him
and then so like he let the golden retriever approach him
but he didn't like give him any attention and then so i was
like okay that's doing good and then but then another dog
came in and then he wanted to it was like a a labrador or a
mud i don't really know um i can't tell um it was either one
or the other it was either mud or a labrador and then he
approached dad And at first, I was like, okay, it's okay.
He's not barking at him.
That's good.
And then he's luring him over, like, false sense of
security.
And then a Labrador was like, there was, like, trying to
smell dad and then, like, smell his head.
And dad was like, that's right.
That's why he's like, ah!
The moment he was like, like, his nose touched him, he was
like, ah!
And then that's the big, by the way, this was a big
Labrador.
He, like, started crying.
He was like, oh!
Big-ass Labrador just started crying.
I was like, oh!
And I'm like, I'm so sorry.
I am so sorry.
Like, he made that sound.
That dog actually made that sound.
Like, the, like, he's like, oh!
And he started, like, running, like, like, backing off and
crouching and, like, oh, turning his head away.
and like whimpering and like I'm so sorry and I instantly
leashed him and we left off because I was like oh no oh no
we have to go now we're not welcome now and then he just
looked at me as I used to that he's like okay I literally
instantly leashed him and I was like we gotta go now we
gotta go home it's like okay
yeah and then yeah i was like we gotta leave we're not
welcome here um but yeah anyway that's the that update for
today what are updates oh yes our second last guest um has
been announced and it is for those who have yet to see check
on twitter it is which also reminds me i have to start
tweeting retweeting the announcements because i've i've been
all over the place uh let's see let me oh saved it in the
wrong folder yet again yes all right but but but but but but
yes our next guest is amalie amalie is our next uh guest for
doki doki rewind time so i'll So she'll be seeing, I think
this is her debut for her 3D model too.
So this will be the first time.
This might be, it might not be, I don't know.
Maybe she'll debut it before the concert.
But it's her first use of her 3D model.
She was telling me how she had this 3D model sitting in the
closet for like months now.
When she was still in V.
Shojo, she had this, like she was trying to figure out how
to debut this 3D model.
so she was like super excited like oh my god can finally use
my 3d model um so uh you will be seeing her 3d it's so cool
her yeah it's it's absolutely beautiful i saw it it's
beautiful um so yes amalie is our uh next guest uh this is
our second last guest i know i said i had like two more but
uh unfortunately uh or for unfortunately fortunately
whatever it is
uh uh our next the next guest is our last guest announcement
yay uh basically what happened was uh we had one we were
supposed to have two more guests but uh it's one more guest
because uh something happened um like there was conflicts
with scheduling wise for chibi's guest uh so the next guest
uh is our last guest yeah
so you know yeah stuff happens stuff happens but I'm still
super excited to be able to sing and perform with all these
talented talented creators and singers next guest is mine it
is my guest so all the guests are my guests so yeah I'm
looking forward to the last one that will be announced
It was unfortunate, but, you know, stuff happens.
Like, I still hope we can still pull off such an amazing...
I know, I know, not hope.
I know, we can still pull off an amazing concert.
You know, a little bit of difficulty, like, a little bit of
technical difficulties behind the scenes.
We're doing our best.
We're doing our best in pulling all of this off.
so uh yes in the next three days will be the final guest
announcement for the concert and then that will be all of
them anyway please welcome omelette oh my gosh i'm so
excited uh for the song me and omelette are gonna sing
together uh we were both like we gotta she was like we have
to sing this like i gave her the list of songs that i got
proven and she's like we have to sing it's like oh my like
yes yes i'm so happy you picked that song because i was i
was waiting for someone to pick this song so yeah amalie is
our second last guest announcement oh my gosh it's almost
almost to the end almost to the end of the guest
announcement it's been super fun so far announcing everybody
um what else what else um what else to have to talk about
i'm trying to think Is there anything else that I'm missing?
Oh, Oshi Uplink was very fun.
It was a first-time convention in Canada.
And for those who didn't know, my event manager actually
helped organize Oshi Uplink as well.
And my manager was the one that connected her to a lot of
YouTubers and stuff.
So he was the one that gave her all the contacts to some of
the VTubers.
that joined Oshi Uplink and I'm really happy that it was
such a success and a lot of people had a lot of fun at Oshi
Uplink.
Yeah, my event manager was one of the head staff that made
it possible.
So I'm super proud of them.
I did her event for free because like I said, she did a lot
for me and you know, I was just like, you don't have to pay
me.
I'm totally down to do it for went really really well yeah
uh yeah so yay oh yeah i remember because like i was the one
that also like was like being like because like uh it since
it was a first time convention i was like telling miss like
did you get an invite to oshi uplink and she's like yeah but
we're not sure because it's a first time convention so we
don't know like we don't really know the staff there's like
you should do it you should do it you should you and then
set to should do the convention
I was like, oh, well, now that you say that, now I feel more
safe and comfortable doing the convention, now that I know
that it's like from a trusted staff.
Because, you know, like, since it's like a first thing, I
was like, I vouch, I vouch.
You should totally do it.
But it was like a first time convention.
You know, people are worried that it's like a scam or
something or like, oh, they don't really know the staff.
so they're like oh will it be will it go okay and everything
I was just like trying to reassure people it's like no it's
okay it's okay the convention will be fine I trust I trust
her it has my seal of approval so yeah it was great I had a
great time at the convention As always, buying Doki merch,
Dave, sex being sexy Doki's first time, paneling and meeting
all the lucky dragons.
Oh yeah, like sexy Doki was also at the meeting degree.
And also, so like two or three lucky dragons gotta meet sexy
Doki.
goons get to have a meet and greet with sexy dokey and so
like basically what i do for meet and greet now is i'm
making a gotcha so like it's a gotcha depending on what type
kind which dokey you get which dokey in the dokeyverse you
get the meet and greet so every person i meet gets a new
dokey to me so um it's like do you win your do you win the
gotcha life's a gamble i'm gonna keep you on you know yeah
that's so fun so three very very lucky dragons got sexy
dokey can't even get on you you can never escape gambling
like
um hi flex thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
i enjoy living your head rent free and just got a flat
screen TV to sit back and watch the screen anyways when's
round three come back to Oshi Uplink and I will defeat you
again that's right guys I was definitely undefeated at the
1v1 apex uh panel and and if you hear otherwise if you hear
otherwise it's fake news it's AI fake news one every single
one i have vouchers i have i have witnesses it's like the
boys where um the boys where they're like yes all times
homelander has killed someone it is ai generating
that's right it is propaganda spread by I'm believers.
That's fucking right.
Anyway, I'll see you next year.
And I will beat you again.
Next scene.
Thank you.
Really got your little convincement to guest at O'Shea
Blank.
It was such an amazing event.
Thank you.
Those damn starlighters.
Exactly.
You know I'm on the right place in history when I identify
myself as home lander, you know I'm on the right side of
history.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I was so lucky.
It was great to chat again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
It was really an honor to meet you.
And it was an honor to meet you guys too.
Like I said, I love doing these meeting greets and just
meeting all my dragons um papa smurf thank you for super
chat thank you thank you is it lucky if i asked for it thank
you to the super chat thank you thank you gordon thank you
the super chat thank you thank you propaganda is not when
australians take a good look at something thank you the
super chat thank you thank you anyway it's time i'm gonna
time travel a little bit because i do want to know what the
game is like when it's in the morning give me a sec Let me
pull...
That's not what I wanted to do.
There we go.
I don't want to play during the night.
I want to know what it's like when it's morning.
The game punishes me by time travel.
No.
Oh!
Wait, it's evening.
Sunset.
Okay.
They'll be able to build.
Good idea.
I'll do it later.
I want to know what they're up to.
Oh my god, it's not nighttime.
Oh, hello.
Ooh, smoked salmon?
Oh my god, that's bougie as hell.
Give me that smoked salmon.
What do they have?
Oh, they have a cookie.
Smoke salmon, salami, panini.
Thank you very much.
I have $52.
All right, let's see.
I got a shop real quick before I...
Oh my god.
I have to buy this.
All right.
I don't even know how much money I have.
I don't need a no.
There's a t-shirt with cars.
A crazy colored shirt.
Work from home.
Monkey.
Oh my god.
Wait, all these clothes today.
There's a...
Oh, there's a little bear hat.
I must have.
it there's a whistle what's this what is this oh it's a bear
tail oh oh my god wait dokey bear wait i can make dokey bear
oh my god there's a chain cargo pants just in time just in
wait is this a flight attend just in time for my concert
let's buy that just in case all right Oh my god, there's
also a Gothic dress.
Oh, but it doesn't really match.
Well, you need Doki Bear, we do.
Is there anything else?
Anything new?
Casual cardigan.
I don't know, bum.
I don't think if there's anything that...
Unfortunately, we don't have any worker outfit.
Oh my god, there's a Waldo shirt.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
I'm not broke yet.
We don't know.
If I always cover the money, we'll never know if I'm broke
or not.
Wait, if I get...
Oh.
Say, if I cover the money, I can live in bliss ignorance.
I can just live in ignorance.
Well, we need that, actually, though, for Gru from
Despicable Me.
I don't know what to do.
Doki it's time hello Doki are you hungry you need I can't
tell are you hungry
all right it's time getting the monkey costume
not sure that went well I think you look beautiful She and I
have our fights, but we always make up She hates it, monkey
Uh Man, I think it was super chat, thank you I literally
just ate smoked salmon Also, please make one of the me's
dad's hot Hot dog He's so funny Which donkey though?
Which one do you fight with?
I'll never know I don't know which donkey it is There's so
many donkeys Oh, hey, Groo.
Oh, you're working here now?
Alright, anything new?
Okay, no, no new rooms.
Okay, there's too many tokeys.
I don't know which one.
Alright, Groo.
What's going on?
What do you mean?
It's Kevin from the minion.
Minions!
Do you think Kevin from the Minions movie?
Yes!
Oh my god, absolutely!
Absolutely!
Oh yeah!
Now I'm kinda curious about him.
Oh my god, yes!
Yes!
It writes itself!
The script!
I can see the script right now.
It's his only friend too.
I see the script guys.
Okay, goods.
What kind of goods should we give him?
Ooh, we should give him a laptop.
Wait, when did I get a laptop?
We should give him a...
Actually, yeah, a laptop.
Here, take this.
Wait, actually, no.
I actually know.
We have to give the laptop to Doki because she needs to
start a streaming career.
Here, get a camera.
Here you go.
You gave him a camera.
Hmm.
Yay!
All right, let's, I also need to give him, uh, oh, you're
hungry, hungry.
Here I have a nacho.
Oh, well, never mind.
I guess have an egg.
Yay!
All right, he was hungry.
All right, guru.
Oh, he likes fried eggs.
Nice.
All right, I also need to give you shoes.
You're not wearing purple shoes.
You got a match.
I'm pretty sure Groo has black shoes.
There we go.
Yeah, now he looks perfect.
Yeah, he likes it.
He loves the shoes.
All right.
Oh, yeah, here, let me...
Oh, I'm trying to pet you.
Mm-hmm.
You don't fucking me every day.
I just gave it to you.
So I know you're lying.
Alright.
Yay!
He really liked that.
Who's a good boy?
That's right.
That's you, Guru.
He's gonna steal the moon now.
Alright, what else?
Oh, Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Hello, Doki.
Good evening.
What do you mean?
What else do you need?
You look perfect!
Maybe better shoes?
I'll grab you some shoes.
Maybe he just wants shoes.
Or socks.
The holy socks.
Oh my.
Oh wait.
Because it has holes in it.
Okay.
He's so ungrateful.
What do you mean he wants more?
I'll give him some shoes.
I'll give him some sandals.
Some shower sandals.
There you go.
And that's perfect.
Sandals with the wizard outfit.
What do you mean?
Now your toes are out.
Is that what you want?
Your grippers are out now.
Oh my god, he's wearing...
Oh my god.
It's because you're wearing socks with it That's why Don't
worry, I can fix this I know why you don't like it It's
because you're wearing socks With those sandals There we go
Now There go Now it fits Now it's up Is everyone having a
good time Where's Kevin why is everybody outside a man the
day oh my god come on get out of here it's a beautiful day
outside you know what get in here you're gonna talk with Rue
actually whoa whoa actually no he's I don't he's taking
pictures right now yo go meet Doki uh hey Doki Kevin from
the minions movie good evening hey Oh, that's it.
Oh, Gru doesn't like it.
He's like, what are you doing, Kevin?
He's like, what are you doing?
They're speculating about places other than Doki Island.
There is only one island here on Doki Island.
Oh, Gru isn't like, doesn't like it.
He's jealous.
He's...
He's a little jealous right now.
He's like, how dare you have a conversation without me?
Groo!
He's so ungrateful to send him to the other island.
They must not know about the other island.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I think we can make another doki.
I think it's time.
All right, Adamie.
All right, let's see.
What doki shall we make?
pull up the dokeypedia i always forget the url for this guys
what's the url for the dokeypedia oh the dokey dokey no me
con wait what does that mean
what does dokey no me con mean it's not a dokeypedia all
right let's see what do I make?
Oh, I know what else.
Oh, yeah, by the way, for those who didn't know, okay, wait,
I'll make it, and then I know exactly what to make.
Alright, let me...
Okay, wait.
Give me a second.
I need to find something real quick.
Oh, next Necronomicon.
What does that mean?
Necronomicon.
Oh, it's a Grimmar.
Oh, that's what it means.
A book of knowledge.
Oh, oh, that's clever.
All right, guys.
I know exactly who to make.
give me a sec I need to look for it okay give me a sec I
need to find something real quick alright oh fuck okay let's
see if I can make this oh y'all no laugh is bad what you
mean what do you mean mean guys I'm trying to figure it okay
I need to make like the easiest version of this this is a
little hard to make so I gotta make the easiest version of
this All right, let's see it.
Bum, bum, bum.
Maybe this?
No, even that one's hard.
Where is an easier version?
Why are all these versions so hard?
All right, this would be the easiest.
All right.
I got it.
You guys gonna be a little confused, but it's all gonna come
together.
Trust.
Trust me.
It's all gonna come together.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Kits.
I don't trust you.
guys now do you understand
what is this guys trust it's all gonna come together it's
all gonna come together guys okay it was like which one was
it it was like this one right or was it Was it this hair?
Yeah, it was this one.
There we go.
Alright, and then...
Which eyes do I use?
It was nice.
Like, what do you mean?
It's donkey!
It's...
It's Doki!
Is this eye or this one?
Oh, it's this one.
And
then...
Oh, is this used as...
Wait, what do I use this for, though?
Wait, no, wait.
I assume that...
I'm trying to figure out what this is for.
But,
um...
Okay.
Uh, no.
Oh!
No, I don't understand.
I...
But it's Tuesday, though.
It's always Monday somewhere in the world, guys.
So it's always Monday somewhere in the world.
Trevor, they want me to use this, but I'm like, where?
Wait, oh, that's...
Wait, is it?
That's where?
Is it?
Oh!
I get it.
Oh, wait.
You'll understand soon.
It's
like...
Is it?
No, that doesn't work.
Fuck this.
I don't get it.
Alright, none.
Oh, wait.
Nose is like...
Oh, that's smart!
There we go.
And then...
Wait, how do I make it pink?
Oh, I had to color it pink later.
Okay.
And then after that, because I can't color, yeah, I can't
color it now.
Oh, whoops.
And then mouth is, where is it?
And then I expando.
Oh, wait, the eyes gotta be bigger.
I just realized.
Let me make the eyes a little bigger.
Oh, it's all coming together, guys.
Yeah.
And then...
No ears.
No glasses.
I gotta figure out which doke field I want to make.
And then...
Wait, why do I have to make up like that?
Where does the dot go?
Where do you...
Oh, does the dot...
No, we don't need the dot.
I'm like, where is the makeup?
Oh, it's for the shading on the eye!
Yeah, we don't need that.
Trust the process, guys.
You're going to be like, okay, but Doki, like, you're
missing so much.
Don't worry.
Trust the process.
This is where magic happens.
This is like putting makeup on, like actual makeup.
Just gotta trust the process.
oh oh oh
what is it oh i still need to remember how to do this
okay okay we gotta put this at the top how do i
wait why is this not painting on top wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute why is this not on top wait a minute my
process said this would work um
oh uh give me a sec please continue to trust the process
uh what do you mean i can't paint on the nose they were able
to paint on how are they able to paint on the nose oh my god
what's this like no this is on may 1st how did she do it how
did she paint on the nose just Oh, she drew the nose.
Oh, this person drew the nose.
All right, but you gotta remove your nose.
I gotta get your nose out of the way.
I realize this person drew their Garfield nose.
Oh my God, I thought I was so smart.
Oh, like, for some reason, I thought I was like...
All right, it's okay.
I have the basic template now.
It's okay.
We have the template.
Got your nose, Garfield.
Don't worry.
Continue to trust the process.
How the fuck do I...
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's beautiful.
Okay.
And then...
Oh, it's the fucking...
Okay.
I hate that.
I hate that it's so hard to...
I hate that it's so hard to, like, move my mouse to the
thing I want to move to.
Okay.
And
then...
Oh, my God.
Perfect.
Boom!
Oh, my...
I'm so good at this.
I am a natural born artist okay now I gotta figure out how
to do the the rest of this I gotta figure out how to do the
rest of this give me a sec I gotta think okay it's okay give
me a sec I'm trying to figure this out all right all right I
realized that The hair might be the hardest part out of all
of it.
The hair might be the hardest.
We'll leave the hair last.
We'll let future Doki handle the hair.
There must be an easier way to, like, go through, like, the
controls and stuff.
Oh, there is.
I had to just press X.
Alright, there was.
There you go.
Okay.
Alright.
I hope Doken Field doesn't get a child.
I heard the face paint comes.
Is hereditary.
A child can inherit the face paint.
And it's not going to be pretty.
It's not going to be so good.
The child will not turn out great.
With what I'm doing.
Okay.
Alright.
Did you guys know that Mies can get a divorce and it just
happens randomly too?
I was talking about it to my friend and they're like, what
if your Mies divorce?
I was like, that's not gonna happen.
They're not gonna teach kids about divorce.
And now they're like, are you sure?
And I Googled it and there's like, and I look up the first
video that pops up when you Google it is like Peach and
Mario divorcing in Tomodachi life.
But yeah, they apparently, um, I was like, There's no way
Nintendo's going to teach kids about divorce.
And...
Yeah, so apparently, the me's kid...
It's not forever.
The canon will divorce, guys.
Alright, let's see.
And then what do I have to do now?
I'm looking...
Yes, I am looking at a guide on how to draw Garibio.
Yes, I have to.
It's fucking Garfield
Oh my I think Okay wait How fuck do I draw Garfield?
Okay Okay It might need to be like a little Okay I'm gonna
do a little Easier Garfield Try Okay Okay Okay Oh, God.
Okay.
And then...
Alright, that's fine.
That's...
That's fine.
It's almost there.
Okay, wait, I can...
I'll erase it to be prettier.
Oh, God.
Alright.
Okay.
There you go.
And then...
Yes, exactly.
The Mona Lisa wasn't painted in a day, guys.
It's all coming together.
Anyway.
Oh, yeah.
At Oshi Uplink, to be incognito, I went around as my Oshi
do.
You know, in the spirit of Oshi Uplink.
I went around as Doka Field Looking at artist alley and
stuff And people were like Is that Doki?
But yes, Doki Field was at Oshi Uplink And people were not
Not in the wiser
They're like Can't believe that was Doki That's me
Okay, what's the color for it?
yellowish.
Like, how would they know?
It's like this, right?
Yeah, it's like that.
Alright.
Okay, I thought this was gonna go behind.
Excuse me.
How the fuck do I paint this from behind?
Okay.
We'll outline this real quick.
I have an idea.
How do I do this from a different layer?
No, it's dark in field.
How the fuck?
Okay, it's fine.
I'll just do this.
Okay, and then all I have to do is down because it can't
draw over eyes and then okay all right it's coming together
oh my god everything's coming together and then oh
boom all right you see the vision guys
slow and steady Rome wasn't built in a day
okay oh my god it's coming together I told you guys okay um
maybe the nose should have been a little bigger but you know
oh I might have I should have maybe moved oh Oh, maybe I
should have moved the nose up a little bit.
Oh, it looks just a little weird.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
We're going to click done.
We're going to fix this, guys.
All right, so what we're going to do is, all right, guys,
guys, guys.
All right, so what we're going to do, guys, is you do this.
grab the nose we oh my god we make it a little bigger put it
here and then uh don't worry it's all it's so fixable and
then where's the mail
Oh fuck
Okay I can fix this And then And then we go back to face
paint We add it And oh Okay and then Okay
Oh my god, it's so fixable.
I fucking knew it.
It's salvageable.
Okay.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh.
Oh, no, wait.
There we go.
See, look at that.
Everything is fixable.
Oh.
God, I hate pixelized.
so much I hate I mean I hate drawing pixel art it's my worst
I'm so bad at pixel art
pixel art is my biggest weakness look I have to draw the
garfield part before I could draw the doka field part guys
it's a process you gotta trust the process
yeah yeah and then
what if this is the entire stream i just draw him and then
we end the stream we can't even i'll never know what daytime
is like on dokey island
what is daytime like over there i'll never know
yeah it'll be so worth it guys trust me it's gonna be so
worth it and you're all gonna be like we added Doki Field to
Doki Island.
Oh my gosh, she's my favorite character.
She's the life of the party.
I'm so happy we decided to add her.
Oh, what will we do about Doki Field?
What will we do?
She surely is the life of the party.
Okay.
Okay, and then we Copy And then Oh Flip Oh Oh fuck, no, not
like that
Okay Copy
Copy Which one is flip?
ZL Flip Oh shit Alright, very Slowly, slow and steady.
Oh my god, where is it?
Is it like that?
Bam!
Alright.
Okay.
Now, all we need to do is add the hair.
Okay, I gotta get Doka field out.
I don't remember what.
Okay.
Alright.
all right now I just gotta save docker field because I don't
remember exactly what docker field looks like give me a sec
all right okay save all right now I just need a reference
sheet of docker field's head or docker field's hair
There we go.
Okay.
Okay, I just need to figure out the hair situation.
That's it.
All right.
We can do this.
It's all coming together, guys.
It's all coming together.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to change the hair color.
Give me...
Okay.
Hair color.
i don't even remember i think it was this color yeah it was
this
yeah a little shine too whoa we oh my god look at that shine
oh my god i told you it's all coming together was that the
right here i don't even know was it this no it was
definitely that to wait unless
wait is this match better
wait which matches but oh my god I've already lost track of
which what I use I use this one right
okay I feel like yeah dockerfield needs I'm never gonna do
that just because like dockerfield needs a shorter base oh
I'm not done we I'm not done oh my god but it's looking so
good though it's like
Oh, Sarah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, right, the entire line for the me and Green sign and
collected the spare in a second.
They saw the sexy toky tweet.
Sarah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Oh, shit, wait.
What happened to my highlight?
Give me a sec.
I got, oh my God.
This is the hardest me I've ever done.
This is the...
The hardest me I've ever done.
Oh, I can only do either a highlight.
Okay.
That's fine.
I thought I could do both.
We'll make it lighter.
Okay.
Back to...
Back to perfection.
Alright, so what we need...
Okay, give me a second.
I think I...
I need a smaller brush.
Oh, it's all coming together.
Yes!
Okay.
It's all coming together, guys.
Thank you.
Why couldn't you do this?
I don't...
Oh, shit!
Why couldn't you do this?
For the Doki Prime.
It's different.
It's so different.
Okay.
It's not the same, guys.
You won't understand.
It's not the same.
Okay.
why does it actually look good anything for maoshi i'll do
anything for him do it for him
oh my god it's all coming together oh my god oh my god
It's all coming together.
Okay, wait.
Oh, I can't.
All right, it has to be.
Okay.
Does that work?
Maybe.
Okay.
All right.
Fuck it.
Oh, my God.
It doesn't work like that.
Okay, I have an idea.
Are we gotta figure out how to do the backside of the hair?
Yeah, it's too small.
No, it's all gonna work out.
It's all gonna work out, guys.
Trust the process.
Okay.
And then we gotta erase this part.
And then we gotta...
Okay.
We can do this.
Trust the process.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Okay.
And then...
Okay, you might be like, oh, but it doesn't blend so well.
See it.
This is...
This is where we add...
Shading.
Okay, it doesn't blend that well.
Uh...
Never mind, never mind, okay.
Wait, maybe unless I'm making more orange.
Oh, how do we make this work?
How do we make this work?
How do we make the rest?
Wait, wait, I got an idea.
I got an idea.
We got the top part down, chat.
Wait, we got...
okay i have an idea i have an idea all right
okay we might have to okay
i have an idea guys okay give me a sec i'm cooking right now
hey give me a oh my god i i told you oh my god i knew it i
okay all right all right We're figuring it out.
We're figuring it out.
Can you let me cook?
Let me in that kitchen.
Oh my god.
It's all coming together.
I told you guys.
Gotta keep on believing.
What is that color though?
I wish I know what that color is.
What is that color?
I want to add another swoop in the back.
Oh, fuck it.
That's fine.
We'll leave it as it is.
It's as good as it can get.
Okay.
And then we'll add.
Okay, we just got to add.
Okay.
Don't feel it.
I need you to move down here.
okay so i can't figure out the ear situation all right so
this is how we're going to do the ears
and then okay
i just want to be sure all right
okay oh
my god oh my god okay we can do this
And then I use up all the space here.
And then
it's all coming together.
Look at that hand control.
God, I wish there were layers here.
I wish there were layers.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, there are?
How do I make it layers?
How do I do it?
How do I use layers?
Wait, if I do this...
That is not a layer.
I don't understand.
How did you guys do layers?
I'll see no layer.
This is pro.
Is there another pro?
No, this is easy.
I'm a pro already.
I'm already on pro.
What are you guys talking about?
This is pro layer.
Is he on the layer button?
No, he's not.
Eh.
Liars.
I think it might be too big.
I don't know.
I might have made it too big.
I might have to shrink it up a little.
You need to select.
Then it shows up on the left.
But I didn't select it, though.
That's different.
Do you think it's too big?
The ears?
Do you think it's a bit too big?
I think I can fix it.
Maybe.
The only issue is that it takes up the entire goddamn year.
Oh, my God.
Okay, that's a little better, actually.
Oh my god, wait, that actually I fixed it.
I think I fixed it.
There you go.
Boom!
Okay, and then...
Okay, wait.
We can fix the ear a little bit more.
Okay.
I might be going crazy just listening to this song on
repeat, but I can do this.
There we go.
Is this the center?
Oh my god, it's not.
Tokyo, not related to the idea that was found dead.
The Duchess has been absent for many months.
Becoming a crazy cat lady.
Wow, the Duchess has been in that room for a very long time.
You don't understand.
It has to be perfect.
Okay.
Then we pour that in.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's all It's working Okay, all right We just need to
get the Oh my god, it's actually Working, it's all coming
Together Okay, now
There we go
This is my Masterpiece This me will get everything he ever
wanted Okay, let's This me will get everything he ever
wants.
This is now my favorite child.
Yeah.
Yeah, he doesn't know outline is needed.
I think it's fine.
I think you would understand.
I don't think you need an outline.
Okay.
Now we just need to...
This is even more than Kevin.
Okay.
I just got, I need to test out the paint.
I don't understand.
What does paint behind even mean if it's not painting
behind?
Like, oh.
Oh my god.
It was not painting behind.
okay
wait not that wait doesn't he be circular how does it look
like
I'm an idea
okay oh my god it's all coming together oh my god my vision
the vision do you see it do you see the vision okay
all right okay we got one down all right
oh my god i'm trying to get to the other side
thing was supposed to be here somewhere i can't remember
okay
oh all right and then what all right
okay maybe not like that
Smooth.
Okay, maybe not.
What do you mean this was?
Are you serious?
That was the dropper this entire time?
Okay, it's fine.
I learned it now.
Okay, maybe not like that.
Maybe not smooth.
What is there?
Okay, that changes the color.
Okay, now I'm learning.
Oh, that's where you should.
shade that's the shading button i understand oh oh
yes okay
we just gotta copy and paste this
oh god not like that
there you go all right one part of the face done okay
all right and then
oh my god it's perfect
progress i'm seeing the vision
oh yes yes oh
my god oh my god it's all coming together
And then we copy this.
And we move it to the other side.
Move it here.
There we go.
I think we did it.
I think we actually need to refine this a little.
I think we made the...
Oh, wait, the X here.
I almost forgot the X.
I was so proud of myself.
I was like, oh my God, there it is.
There it is.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, I gotta fix that.
Boom.
Oh, my God.
It's perfect.
It's absolutely perfect.
We have Docafield.
Oh, my God.
With a giant-ass forehead.
Oh yeah, you're right.
Maybe I should- you're right.
I should change the color of this a little.
I think this would work, right?
There you go.
Ah, I think.
Definitely a different color.
Like bluish.
Like this.
There.
Oh.
Too light.
There we go.
perfect there we go we spent all right time and time what's
the speedrun what's the speedrun record chat of Docafield
what was it I cannot be bothered to lower the forehead I
know that I know that maybe the forehead is really really
big but this is as good as it's gonna get it was a world
record i knew it i knew it was gonna be a world record and
time all right let me get rid of i could clean up you know
what you know what i'm gonna clean it up a little bit just
because i can oh
Just for fun.
For the love of the game.
Why is there a huge leg?
It's fine.
Okay, this is as good as it's gonna get.
Is it?
It's beautiful.
My life's work right here has led me to this moment.
Don't feel it.
It has led me to create This beautiful masterpiece It can be
like Here The hair on the first Tokey And then The hair on
the first Tokey versus the hair on Doki feels.
See, I've improved.
I have improved, guys.
Doki.
My name is Doki.
Alright.
Okay.
When did... Oh, wait.
It's my birth.
Yeah, July 4th.
Dirty Prime is drowning like a child in the me.
Okay.
Custom.
I feel it.
My name is Doki.
My name is my name.
Okay, wait.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, thirteen.
14, 15, 16, 17, 18.
Apparently, they found the perfect Garfield voice.
So I'm going to try and recreate it.
Create it.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14.
I don't know if it's actually true, but we're going to try
it.
One, two, three.
three four five six seven eight nine ten that's
not it i don't trust this process
i don't trust this
that doesn't sound like joke field
all right wait wait wait this person has another tone What
is this voice sound?
What is this voice sound?
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 5th, 2026.
So, come on.
My name is Doki.
My name, my name is Doki.
My name is, my name is Doki.
That doesn't sound like Phil Murray.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 5th.
My name is Doki.
My name.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 5th, 2026.
My name.
My name is Doki.
I guess I need to look up Garfield real quick.
Garfield.
Bill Murray.
So how does this voice sound?
It sounds sort of.
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Garfield voice acting.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 5th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
It's a little higher, right?
Today, my name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you today.
My name is Doki.
Like somewhere around there, I hate Mondays.
May 5th, 2026.
My name is, my name is Doki.
Sort of, right?
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Doki.
It's my name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
today my name is okay one i think one yeah yeah i hear it i
hear it all right no he's slow he's honest he's pretty flat
he's very chill and then he's very normal he's a very normal
cat
i hear it john p i hate mondays john All right, let's see.
Event outfit.
Is there any more for dating preferences?
So we...
Yeah, we're good.
I think we're good.
Oh, so hungry, John.
So hungry.
Yay!
Outgoing!
Okay, we're gonna fix you.
It's outgoing.
I said, what?
Ow.
All right, we're going to fix you.
This isn't Doka Field.
Really?
Wait, that imposter.
It's nice to meet you.
Duchess 22.
WW.
W, W, W, W, W, W.
Double Ganger.
I'm an outgoing merrymaker.
I'm a social butterfly who loves hanging out with friends.
Yeah, no.
Leave it to me.
No.
Don't get me.
I can't wait to start living here.
Oh, my God.
His mouth goes up to his nose.
All right.
We're going to, we're going to try and fix this.
Uh.
Yeah, no.
how we're gonna brainwash you real quick maybe normal
it's so merry maker okay wait wait he's too chill maybe we
need a lesson to chillness buy the book puts a achiever oh
my god no don't feel we gotta we gotta keep fixing you until
it works.
How is this?
Okay, it's still ambitious.
how about we make you serious?
He's still intelligent, not afraid to show it.
Okay, nope.
We gotta make you lazy.
Where is the lazy?
Okay.
Honest.
He is honest.
Maybe he's too slow.
oh my god it's back to merrymaker and he's back she's back
why are these personalities so happy where's my depressed
personality i gotta lower the honest maybe there we go but
finds a lot thought and innocent okay this is as good as we
can get it's also orange this is actually as good This is as
good as we can get.
We're, yeah, we're like a man's room.
Brainwashing is so high.
Just make energy flat.
All right, let's try it.
Now he's green.
Logical, cautious, speaks.
Okay, no, we made it worse.
We gotta redo this.
Maybe here.
Yeah, we're back to here.
This is as daydreamer.
good as we could get we quirky max as let's max up the
quirkiness see what we get you know just just because we're
lobotomizing people right now let's let's max it up let's
he's a pretty normal i'll put in the middle there we go
since we're we're doing it anyway on him we might as well
continue the science experiment.
Max chill?
I think it would max out chill.
I don't think anything's gonna change.
But yeah, see?
He's still the same.
There's introvert if you put everything.
Alright, let's put everything up here.
Wait, actually, guys, I don't remember my thing.
We put it all here.
It would put it... I feel like Daydreamer, though, works the
best, though, doesn't it?
Oh my god, I don't even remember.
I feel like Daydreamer works the best over-over-introvert,
though, doesn't it?
Yes?
Oh, it doesn't?
Alright.
We'll make him normal, because I feel like he's such a
normal cat.
It does?
Yeah, Daydreamer makes sense.
Alright.
Alright, Doko.
field.
It's as good as we can get.
Let me feed you real quick, too.
I think the brainwash has been successful.
Here, have some smoked salmon.
Lobonomy done.
They don't know how they got here in Joki Island.
All they remember is being strapped in a chair and then
waking up.
All they could remember was that, was they were in a car and
then they woke up here.
Alright.
Alright, let's make you a meal.
Let's make you meet some of the new villagers.
She won't be able to leave it stays this way.
Add some landscaping to connect the main island to the land
around.
Do some press X and select...
Oh my god, I can terraform now!
Where's the lasagna, John?
Let's start with some grass.
Alright.
Now press X to...
Oh, minus to...
Nice.
We can finally terraform.
I'm glad that you can go to other places and meet other
people.
You can terraform.
You can transform and lay off your island in many ways,
including building a new land where the sea used to be.
This can help you connect other areas to make room as
needed.
Hey, if you make the island bigger, it seems like plenty of
mees could live here.
News time!
Me news!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
Not related to other islands is now freely welcoming
residents.
Meaning anyone can- Oh, I should have cleaned up her face a
little bit.
I forgot what it would look like when she closes her eyes.
Finally, a fresh audience.
And our numbers will soon be multitudinous.
There will be no stopping us.
will be infinite thanks for watching i'm doki and you're up
to date yay i become roommates the other means i live by
ourselves right makes sense that means we'll get married
become great friends might want to live together in a bigger
house you help foster these kind of relationships by helping
your means interact with each other give it a try okay i bet
you it's night time now oh no not yet not yet still daytime
let's go i was gonna say i bet you it's nighttime after i
spend it all i'm making doka field
kevin the minion sure what should we talk about joki bird
other oh you should talk about others yeah uh
What's this?
What's Ann?
Oh, oh, it's Ann Banana.
Oh, y'all know that.
Banana.
Yes.
Got it.
I'll go talk to him without a banana.
Yes.
Kevin will like that.
Good evening.
Kevin.
On the minions movie?
Do you feel like talking about...
A banana?
Sure.
Would you say that a banana mix?
Do you think about it?
Okay, um...
Uh, I guess they're both yellow.
Oh, it's true, true.
Hey, I could talk about a banana all day long.
That's true.
They're both yellow.
I think we are friends.
Oh my god.
Bonded by bananas.
Yay!
Now they're friends now.
I think it's fine.
They don't need nicknames.
So easy that.
It's so easy.
That Doki always has something interesting to say.
We did it!
Friendship is so easy.
All you gotta do is talk about bananas.
Look, obviously I can make them talk about more coarse
things, but this all has to stay in character.
I gotta be immersed.
Oh, island build.
New wish is available.
Can lock new types of landscaping that you can use with the
island build it.
Gotta be in character.
Alright, let's see.
I don't think we need any of that.
a tear for him, anything.
Ooh, oh, a seesaw.
Oh, I don't have anything.
Where are you gonna do traffic lights for?
Where the fuck's the car, anyway?
There's no cars here.
Eureka set.
Plesher rooms.
Athletic set.
I don't know what I want.
What about goods?
Do I need good stuff?
Right now, no.
You know what?
Let's grab some whole house stuff.
Or in it.
Oh, cat person.
Or is there a kitchen?
If there's a kitchen.
Oh, there is.
Yes!
Get that kitchen set.
Alright.
Alright, Gru, what do you want?
Good evening.
For Doka Field, of course.
My room.
And here's the new.
Okay.
Uh, entire room.
Do I have enough money?
Oh my god.
You work here.
You have employee discount.
Why do I have to pay you?
You literally have employee discount here.
I mean, there's not really much.
I guess the antique.
I don't have enough money.
These M side dokeys and real sheep can't hurt you, Gavin.
Thank you.
It was a super chat.
I don't have enough money, though.
I don't think so.
Like, a black would be the...
No, actually, this would look like the same.
Yeah, I can't afford it.
Sorry, Gru.
You're gonna...
Gru, you're gonna have to...
You're just gonna wait.
I'm not spending...
I'll give you...
You know what?
I'll buy you a white room.
How about that?
If only I can take on debt.
Exactly.
There you go.
It was $20.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my flashbang.
The light at you.
Oh okay.
Yay!
That was a hit.
It looks great.
That's the boy.
He only has one friend.
Groo, you gotta make new friends.
Why is there?
Oh it's because of the stomach.
I was gonna say it.
Groo, you gotta make new friends, Groo.
You can't be.
Oh my god, there's no...
Another quick tip.
You have to drag a half-whip just to take it.
Well, there's an easier way.
Oh!
Press select up in order to bring them both of them
together.
You know what?
Let's meet...
Doki.
Pardon me?
Could I have a moment?
My name is Groo.
Groove from Despicable Me movie.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Yay!
Now they know each other.
Ooh, they're gossiping.
I wonder what they're talking about.
They're a little gossip.
Oh my god, they're like mine individuals too.
Let's go.
They now know each other.
They know they exist.
They're calling fond memories now.
What about you, Doki?
Good evening.
Wait, are you hungry?
Got you food.
Got you smoked salmon.
Yum.
You're no longer hungry.
Oh, she really liked it.
More than nachos?
More than not?
That's right.
That's my bougie Doki right there.
You got some taste, Doki.
I want to eat something you made with your own hand.
Oh my god, just fed you.
You want to eat something you prepared in that case?
Wait, I have to cook?
Let's build a pallet house workshop.
Another at the pallet house workshop.
All I do is find a place where should it go?
Um, right here.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A pallet house workshop has opened on not related to other
islands.
At the local pallet house, Duchess 22 WWW WWW WWW can make
all sorts of things.
Oh, can I draw my own food now?
Oh, okay, this is where it gets good.
It's about time.
Oh my god, this is it.
This is where we start the game.
Tutorials finally over.
I'm Doki, and you're up to date.
Okay, I gotta fix Doki's face.
Okay, I touched here in the palette.
You can make different creations by drawing pictures.
Now you're ready to make some food.
Why not make your first creation a piece of cake?
We started for you since it's your first one.
So all that's left is for you to give that cake its tasty
finishing touches.
If we're not, try using a stamp to the top of the screen.
Once you're done, press done.
Do I have to make a cake?
Or can I draw something else over it?
Oh, no, it has to be a cake.
All right.
Well, I guess it has to be a cake because there's already a
thing here.
What do I...
Tutorial cake.
I'm thinking.
What do I draw for this cake?
Boy, I can erase it.
Nice.
All right.
Let's erase it.
I have an idea what I want
I need to look up the references Give me a sec Sorry, I need
to look up the references Real quick
Why are you laughing?
Guys, you understand sad you know okay okay sorry sorry this
is very important i know no no dear it's not what you guys
think it is yeah look up the reference give me a sec let
me see if i can find it i
need to look up a reference to make sure to make sure it
looks right
back to the drawing board we go
sorry i saw something okay okay that's exactly all right
i got what i needed
I gotta wait let me give me a sec I gotta make sure it's the
right one I'm looking at
I'm so stupid okay I'm driving up this is the right one I
want to use
Alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, I can use squares.
What am I doing?
That's dumb.
What is she?
cooking.
What could she be cooking right now?
Was that the fight of 87?
Was it not?
No way.
No fucking way.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa,
it's immersion, by the way.
What?
It's technically food.
What are you guys talking about?
There we go.
No, it's food.
It's technically food.
Anyway, here's the crying kid.
The crying child.
Rough and half.
I could have made the other crying child.
I could have made the other one.
all right there we go i think it's perfect i think this
beautifully represents the crying kid for nap i think wait
i'm pretty sure for the sprite i think the feet is a little
taller let me fix that there you go
wait The bite of 69.
Is that the bite of 69?
Oh shit, we have to fix it.
Oh, I have to fix it.
I didn't see the...
Didn't see this.
I'd rather erase this part.
Alright, now it's perfect.
Is that the bite of 69?
It doesn't taste like salty type.
I would say it's a pretty meaty.
Oh, no, it's a meat dish.
Temperature.
Oh, definitely room temperature.
Medium.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, large.
No, it has to be a large.
It has to be a large.
Oh,
please name it anything else
Children, right?
It's a large child Well, fuck, okay, fine, fine
Fine, it's sick Anyways, salty Remember, they wanted me to
change it Gordon wanted me to change the name be a large
child there we go the bite of 67 the creation is now
available from the fresh king of food mark alright let's go
buy the bite of 67 let's buy how many kids were there again
1 2 1 2 3 4 5 alright 5 kids just like in those stories We
got five kids.
Gordon, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
All right, Toki.
Would you like the bite of 67?
Oh, I just feel.
One of those going to turn into Chica now.
Oh, she liked it.
Please ask, please.
Oh,
she liked it.
bite of 67.
So now you're able to create new types of food by using
wishes.
You'll also be able to create new clothing and items.
Use your imagination and create the kind of stuff that you
think will make your me residents happy.
It makes me happy.
If you have any friends nearby, we're playing this game and
use the local play to exchange me's and creations from your
pilot.
Oh, wait, that's cool.
We can share stuff together.
Look at that.
She's so happy.
so full right now she's like yum yum in my tom tom all right
get over here you're gonna meet you're in me at dokey hey
nice to meet you i'm dokey nice to meet you dokey i'm dokey
yay dokey now knows dokey oh she's getting advice from dokey
of people.
Thanks for that.
I'm a lot closer to Doki now.
Her relationship with Kevin, Doki, and Doki.
Oh, nice.
Goods.
Here, here, have a laptop.
You're gonna have to start your streaming career and pay
rent, Doki.
Gave her a laptop.
Yay!
Thank you.
No problem, Doki.
Oh, oh, no.
Oh, no.
He's hiccuping.
I'll bring someone over.
Kevin.
Come over and help.
Oh, wait.
That's not Kevin.
Where the fuck is Kevin?
Oh, there's Kevin.
Kevin.
Go help Gru.
Doki, my FBI agent is threatening me with season is this
because I'm watching a live creation of a certain...
island.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What?
There's something wrong with my island.
I'm gonna be okay.
Though right.
My island is so safe.
You're so kind.
I'm just happy I could help.
Okay.
Surviving now.
Oh, let's feed the all the dokeys.
The bite of 16.
wait what is it dokey oh what are you thinking about dokey
let me look inside oh my god thinking about the bahamas
you i feel so much better now hope you enjoy oh reggae Oh,
she's thinking about the concert right now.
To give it to me, but suddenly you can also give your ball a
little boost, but that requires finding a fire somewhere.
But to construct a...
Oh, a pawn shop!
I get pawn shop now.
I just put it next to here.
I'm fine with that.
Oh, whoops.
I put it a little bit too high.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A very reputable pawn shop has opened on not related to
other islands.
You'll want to visit the right price to sell off any
treasure you don't need anymore.
Locals are responding to the news with, will they buy my
pocket limp?
And I was told this treasure is priceless, but the cashier
sure was glad to put a price tag on it.
Thanks for watching.
Like the best I could do is one dollar.
Pond Wars.
What is it?
Pond Shop?
What is it called?
Pond Shop Wars?
Or, no, not Pond.
What was the...
What was that?
Uh, Pond Shop?
Oh, my god.
Great Price Pond.
Pond Stars?
Yeah, Pond Stars.
I used to watch that.
And then, like, the Grandpa Dad.
And then they just...
And then the Grandpa Dad, and apparently, like, like, um,
everything got super scripted.
They're like, I have a guy.
They'll be like, the super fucking obscure thing.
And they're like, don't worry, guys.
I have a guy.
It's like, they always somehow have a guy.
Yeah, oh yeah.
And then one of them went to prison.
I don't remember for what.
Nice seeing you.
I'm so...
Yeah.
It was like half scripted and half like...
Because it was from the history channel.
So it was more about like learning the history of like
historical items.
And then it was like half scripted and half like actually
real and then they went full scripted think you could get me
some clothes that make me look mysterious mysterious i mean
like you're a cat like someone who has stories to tell but
you know you'll never hear them because i'm so mysterious
you're so mysterious all right let's let's check out What
would Fidoka feel?
I feel like...
New color.
Maybe cars?
Ha ha, straight about cars.
What would Fidoka feel to wear?
I mean, he's a chill guy.
Maybe like...
That?
That's true pajamas, but there's no pajamas right now in the
shop.
You're so right.
If there was pajamas, I'd buy it.
I'm not covering up his face.
I worked way too hard for that.
I worked way too hard drawing his face.
He's never covering up his face, guys.
I'll give him, like, I'll give him this.
Just because I feel like that would fit the most.
I'll give him a chill outfit.
There's honestly nothing in...
Oh wait, that's a cool That pants would work Where is that
pants Do not sell the pants Separately
Because they're working from home With the plaid pants
Yeah, they don't Oh, they don't sell that pants separately
That's bullshit
Okay, I have to buy this and just buy keep the pants yeah
i'm gonna give the pants to him
there we go you got the pajama pants yes right she's just
missing that's how they get you they do that's how they get
me i hope you can spend more time visiting all right all
right you gotta meet some new people Doka Field.
Oh, no, that's not what I wanted.
I want to grab you.
Oh, no.
Alright.
Oh, oops.
Art Doka Field.
You got me another Doki.
Who do you want to meet?
Let's see.
How about you and me?
Doki.
Oh, they're having a conversation right now.
Have we?
My name is Doki.
You Doki?
I'm Doki.
All right, Doki and Doki now knows each other.
Yay!
Doki and Doki now know each other.
Oh, I can have extra... I have enough for a wish.
Wishing time.
Yay!
You're Doki, I'm Doki.
Who here is not a Doki?
Is there anyone here that's not a Doki?
Oh, okay, wait.
I can unlock new crafts.
Treasures, landscaping.
Island, landscaping.
What is that?
What?
No.
Clothing, treasure.
I want treasure or clothes.
How many Doki?
is too many.
How many do keys does it take to change a life of?
Crystal, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
I'm gonna do clothes.
Maybe I'll draw some clothes for my dokeys.
You know, I have a new kind of creation of a palette house.
Wait.
I can make...
I could technically make dokey naked.
I can't agree.
on a recipe for the bite of 67.
I don't know how they make those kids taste so good.
Do you think they feed them?
It's like those like, well, like Wagyu beef where like they
feed the cow, like the cow's the best type of grass out
there.
They free farm it.
Oh my god, wait, is that Garfield modeling?
Wait, wait, that looks sick on him.
Wait a minute.
Wait, that Oh, it looks sick on Dokevillis.
Do they pickle the kids?
Oh, Dokey is working really hard.
I'm like, oh, Dokey, what are you?
No, wait.
Dokey, what are you looking at?
Oh, Dokey's looking at Archive.org right now.
All right, Doki, let's go make you meet.
Let's go have you talk to Doki.
Hey, Doki.
Oh.
Doki, no!
Doki!
Oh my god, he jumps here!
Boo!
All right, Doki.
Oh no, Doki's so scared now.
Oh, Doki and Kevin.
Oh, they're great friends.
Hi, Doki.
Oh, that's it?
All right.
She's a real one for that.
Oh, wait, new stuff.
Welcome.
Oh, it's just that thing.
Is there anything new here?
It's just rocks, right?
Yeah, nothing new.
Why would Doki do that?
To Doki.
So I can make clothes now.
Or your me's into.
And what's your style?
Design a piece that'll let your me's shine.
Okay, I can design hats.
Well, I wanted to make a hat for Doki.
but then it covers her pigtails so it doesn't doesn't matter
what if wait I could technically oh wait okay I was thinking
I could make the tomato naked technically if like I see a
short sleeve shirt and then just paint it red does that work
like that or is there shading
a template use prior creation does that work I'm gonna try
oh it had no it doesn't work because it's just it has the
little little shirt thing never mind all right we'll figure
this out later don't save all right we'll figure this out
later What kind of clothes we want I mean Okay is there
overalls chat Is there overalls in Tomodachi life Because if
there is If there is Guys I know exactly What I wanted Oh
there is okay There's no point in drawing it There is Wait
Doki Come talk to Doki Nice to see you I thought I'd share
this with you.
Oh wait, where did she?
Where did she get burger?
Please I insist but it looks so valuable.
I just can't please.
It's nothing I have she got burger.
I appreciate the thought and that's plenty for me Nonsense
just get the burger Oh my god, you guys are too polite Guys,
come on.
Come on.
You're a doki.
Just eat it.
You're so hungry, dokafield.
What happened?
Aren't you not hungry?
Oh, hello.
Here for a game of shadow quiz.
Okay.
Let's go.
Guess what is casting the shadow?
Here's your first mystery shadow.
What do you think?
Oh, banana split.
The answer is...
Yay!
I recognize those cherries anywhere.
It's Pikachu.
What do you think?
What do you think it is?
The answer is...
I wonder what it was.
167.
And finally, the last mystery show.
Oh, that reminds me, I need to feed the other...
What the fuck is this?
Is this a book?
Oh, yeah, that's a...
That's a book.
The correct answer is...
It's a self-help book.
Self-help book.
Live your best life.
Was that the bite of 67?
Yay!
I win!
Yeah, I win.
Time for your prize.
A big one.
Wait, that's a bear.
Oh, it's like the Splatoon bear.
Alright, Groo, you gotta meet...
Groo!
Meet Dokefield!
Alright.
Everyone has to meet...
Dokey.
Groo from Despicable Me Movie.
Hey, bear.
Wait, has he eaten yet?
Have you had food?
Oh, you're hungry.
Don't worry, I got the perfect food for you.
Oh, not this.
Uh, oh, not this food.
Uh, I know I bought five.
Wait, where's the five kids?
I bought five.
Where is it?
I bought five of you.
Oh, there.
Oh, no, not that.
There you go.
Yum, yum, yum.
They escaped.
Yay!
She liked it.
I got to remember to give each dokey the bite of 67.
All right, where's the other dokey?
All right, dokey.
Wake up.
Oh, I can't.
Why are you dreaming?
Oh, I play Mario.
Wee.
Oh, game over.
She was never good at platformers.
Huh?
Oh, it was just a dream.
Oh, I got mushroom.
all right are you hungry dokey here you go yum
nice she liked it number two the bite of 67 all right which
dokey hasn't eaten yet this dokey has eaten Kevin's just
chilling.
Oh, tomato.
Hey, Doki.
Which one?
Oh, great idea.
Oh, my God.
You guys can be roommates.
We've been spending a lot of time together.
What's something you think we enjoy doing every day?
If Doki's a...
Marvel Rivals having a long chat.
Cabley.
gambling I think you're right I'll go talk to her
there's something I'd like to ask you what's got you looking
so serious all of the above if the two of us live together
what's something you think we enjoy doing every day let's
say it together on three One, two, three.
The one.
I forgot.
Our answers didn't quite line up.
But it might be fun to live together anyway.
My boobs.
Every bum wig.
The bum.
Of course.
Hey, hey, they're now roofing, so it worked.
It's so weird.
They all worked.
Don't you think the house is here?
Oh, no, it's not.
I'm thinking we all need to get a new one.
Let's build a house.
Please choose a location.
All right, we're going to need a bigger house.
It has to be here, right?
Where do I put my vending machine?
I'm sure.
So we'll have a quick time living in this house together.
Say, do you have any idea?
Tax failed successfully.
If you have a good name for us, I'd love to hear it.
Oh, house name.
What should we doky and co's doky and co's house?
Oh my gosh.
Core.
We're the new face clan, guys.
We're the new face clan.
Oh my god, the new streamer house.
Face up, boys, face up.
Face boys.
Then we shall be It's fourth round as phase clan
We're the phase boys Choose that gift
walk?
Oh yeah, he floats.
There's a new member of the Faze Clan!
Sans while shaking his.
There you go.
He's so excited.
Yeah, you are.
What's up with Doki?
Which one?
Oh?
Oh.
Oh no!
Now that's a different match.
He always comes back.
Oh my god.
I changed the look of the other group name.
Just press X to the home.
The home is...
What a match.
Guys, our new streamer house!
Oh my god, our streamer house!
Wait, guys.
Has he eaten it?
Oh, he has.
Wait, has he?
No, he hasn't.
Since we're speaking of the kids.
So have...
Oh, they all like it.
They all like it.
That's how William have to die.
They almost got me.
He almost got me, guys.
Seems like that they're getting used to the island like you
know that they got up to stuff That when you're not watching
wish you can get some kind of daily report Perhaps is an
order once you build when you get all kinds of fun reports
about your me's daily lives All right, I would like that
please I'm like running out of space right now I'll put it
here We have to walk to bring you some fucking news Here's
what's happening on our end
Stop buttoning in daily to make sure that you don't miss a
single stream.
Thanks for watching.
Yay!
We have a new station.
I need to start adding more land.
No, you're right.
Okay, wait.
I'm going to move some stuff around.
It should be here.
And then...
I have a tiny vending machine.
There it is.
There's my vending machine and then I don't think I like
that here.
Let's put this here.
Yeah,
that's good.
What's the daily news?
Hello and welcome to the evening edition of Me News.
Folks, we have an underdog story to report today.
Yeah, Kevin from the minions movie?
In fact, she was scheduled for late day today.
But shockingly, she simply decided to not do it.
for comments doki told reporters that her lazy side went out
it's like a voice in my head was telling me to stay in bed
she said we have to present better reactions i'm not really
interested are you messing with me thanks for watching i'm
kevin from the minions of course joki would be a devil and
then grew will be the angel joki is so evil she's more evil
than grew Oh, yeah, you want to keep forever.
You lock up to 49 stores any given time.
All right.
Oh, dokey's just...
Which dokey hasn't eaten a dokey, a child yet?
I think I fed every dokey's, right?
Yeah, every dokey's.
Face glance, Alice.
All right, let's put in some wishes.
Yay!
New wish!
Level 9!
Have new amenities?
Log fence.
Hmm.
I don't think so.
I'm gonna wait.
Yeah, I'm just gonna wait.
I'm saving up my wishes.
Oh, Doki.
Oh, Doki's hiccuping!
Again!
I'll bring someone.
Doki.
Alright, Doki.
You go help Doki out.
Are you alright?
They won't stop.
And this?
Oh, I think you're on to something.
Yeah!
Thank you.
Well, really?
You're okay?
We did it.
We helped Doki.
Alright.
What else?
What else can we do right now?
Is it...
Oh, wait.
Quick build of Mennonies.
Oh, is it for...
Oh, it's the news station.
Why would I build more than one news station, though?
Oh, look, they're playing.
Oh, look.
Alright, Kevin.
Talk to Gru.
Since you two are such good friends.
Good evening.
Gru from Despicable Me Movie.
Do you feel like talking about...
Gambling?
Gambling.
Sure.
Cool.
Well, I have to say, I've been super into gambling.
Oh no!
Really?
Okay, that's good.
At least they're both on the same page.
I totally come around on the choice of gambling.
We should hang out sometimes and do that.
I am no, Kevin!
No!
Think about your savings.
What have you done, Tokey?
He's about to hit it big.
Oh, they're good friends.
They bonded over Gamba.
Nice.
I knew gambling would bring groups from Despicable Me Movie
and Me Together.
Makes sense.
A stream is sponsored by Polymarket.
It's not.
It's not sponsored.
Man, Despicable Me 4.
It's turning out to be a really good movie, guys.
I'm really enjoying Despicable Me 4, guys.
What are you doing in Phase Clan right now?
Oh, they're eating!
Oh my god, they're sharing a meal!
Nice!
I think it's time to make a new dokey.
It's time to add another dokey into this.
Into this island.
Alright, new dokey time.
New dokey.
Alright, grabbing my dokeypedia.
Give me a sec.
We gotta spice it up a little bit.
Dokey.
Oh my god, I already forgot the URL, guys.
Oh, dokey McGrunt.
Alright, new dokey time.
Let's see.
Which dokey do I add?
Uh Which dokey do I add this time?
Bum
I would if I could Wait, I think I could Alright
Wait, I think I can
Is there shorter?
Somewhere
Wait, maybe I can.
I think I can.
Witch toky!
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to figure this out.
Try to figure out the hair.
Give me a sec.
This here, yeah, I think.
Alright.
More like a line.
Showing a reference right now.
Everything will be revealed in time.
It will all be revealed after these messages.
I'll be reviewing after these messages.
What
do you mean?
What do you mean, guys?
Let's see.
perfect mouth for this I think this there's still time to
cool it it's
too late it's too late oh I gotta change the skin color too
oh yes yes Give us Masotaki, you swear they were back in the
field.
Lolly, thank you for the streaming chat.
Thank you.
It's never too late.
I have so much practice now.
The best part, guys, is that I can put this.
I need to have this on screen.
Look at the reference.
That's the best part.
All right.
And then the hair.
This is where I submit my dragon two weeks notice.
Guys, it's Doki.
That's your favorite Doki, guys.
It's your favorite Doki, everybody.
I'm getting better at this, too.
Isn't that crazy?
I'm getting so good at this.
Here we go.
And then...
I officially tapped out.
What do you mean, guys?
The Doki!
So beautiful.
Oh, my gosh.
They're like, yeah.
They're so beautiful.
Okay.
And then...
Do the highlight.
And then the X.
The X marks the spot.
Oh, wait.
I gotta change the color.
Look at that.
Beautiful.
Alright, we gotta fix the face a little bit more.
I think we can...
improve it
we definitely fix the face yeah we do that I did this we do
that and then move it down a little oh I have that yeah we
gotta move this eye a little
bit okay okay I can I know what to do and I lower the hair a
little bit all I have to do I lower the hair and it'll be
perfect Wait, unless...
Okay, there's a little bit of a five.
I think I might just have to settle with this.
You need to stop.
But she's so sexy.
How can I stop when she's so sexy?
Oh, yeah, this works better like that.
Unless we do it.
this.
No, it has to be this.
Yeah, there we go.
She's single?
Ladies, ladies, calm down.
There's enough sexy jokey for everybody.
Let me fix the hair a little bit.
Let me fix the makeup.
There we go.
We are very lucky to meet her.
Oh, calm down, ladies.
There's so much of sexy Doki to go around.
Oh, I'm George.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, does sexy Doki have ears?
I don't think so.
No, she does not.
years it should turn lips be a little bigger or is it just
good enough oh definitely there we go
maybe this here yeah there we go
like this
dokey oh that's true we gotta fix the bangs give me a sec
My name is D.
You're right.
Might need to fix the bad situation.
I think here would work.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
As long as she doesn't turn around, right?
As long as she...
As long as she doesn't turn around.
Bump.
Let me do this, actually.
Yeah, we'll just keep it here.
Yeah, I think it's good.
Alright, right here.
Doki.
My name is Doki.
Oh, it was faster.
It went the other way.
Is she tiny?
I don't remember.
We have too many tiny ones.
Oh, I already passed it.
All right.
My name is Doki.
Oh, definitely a two.
It's nice to me.
My name is Doki.
It's my name is Doki.
My name is my name is Doki.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is May 5th, 2026.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's pretty, yeah.
Very quirky.
I'm thinking of Super Chat, thank you.
It's just sexy, Tokyo.
What are you talking about?
Lawful, honest, innocent, do-us-things-things-things-things!
their own face no we gotta fix that we gotta fix that dokey
let's build a house for dokey from now on you'll be a place
to house anywhere you like on the island please choose a
location for dokey's house all right here
your duchess 22 w w w w w w w w right it's nice to meet you
i'm a considerate eat you i know i'm a plus i have it all
together but i've been known to overthink things now and
then i hope we get along well
all right dokey oh maybe i do need to fix your hair a lot
maybe oh it's fine it works oh yeah before we before we do
this we gotta feed you since we have another dokey in dokey
island here's a here's a child
she liked it yeah
all right now we got a fixer another lobotomy oh yeah and i
also have to do a dating preference too
all right uh okay
maybe a pier what does this give me optimist passion it
follows their wit and charm it's never a dull moment when
they're around you know what that's true that's true I take
those alright oh I can edit her lingo talking about secrets
they're supposed to be secret alright let's have you meet
the other doki's oh let's give you a little pat too yeah oh
oh dad wants to get involved
all right it's time for you to meet the other doki's doki
well something oh
when she opens her eyes guys who should she meet who should
doki meet guys We have Doki, Doki, Doki, Kevin, Grew, and
Doki.
Which Doki?
Grew?
Doki!
No!
What?
Oh, wait, but he's talking to Kevin!
We need to give her to someone that he's not talking to.
Wait, everybody's hanging out with each other.
Is there anyone that's not hanging out with anyone?
All right, we're going to interrupt this so Gru can meet
Doki.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Hello there, Doki.
I'm known as Gru from this, the couple, me movie.
Perfectly suited in the evening wood.
Jap, kanji?
How is that suited for the movie?
mood.
Alright, let's put some wishes in.
Is Doki and Doki gonna do anything?
Are you guys still eating?
Oh my god, all you guys do is eat!
Make her meet everyone?
Alright, where is Doki?
Alright, Doki.
Go be social.
Now meet Kevin.
hey nice to meet you i'm dopey nice to meet you dopey i'm
kevin from the minions movie all right she's meeting
everybody is lally defending son's undertale passion choices
wait i know what to make now
No, it's in me.
I-
I gotta pull up my reference.
Where's the tan color?
Okay.
And any green?
And
then...
Wait, no, it should be like down here.
Oh shit, no, that's not what I wanted.
Alright, and then...
With this...
It's like...
There we go.
Oh wait.
It should be like...
Oh my god, it should be like that.
Oh my god.
Yes!
It's like those...
Yeah, it's like those aprons!
It's exactly like those aprons.
Okay, I gotta fix this though.
So it works.
Oh, wait, you're right.
It shows over this.
Oh, shit, you're right.
This will work too This makes it better On the back I could
try a new Wait what does it look like if I Toki Sir, you
will see my chat Thank you, thank you Oh, I could do it like
that though You're right
Oh my god, that looks so classy though You're so right Do I
do it like this?
that and then do it like that instead.
Oh, you guys are so right.
This would look so much classier if I do it like that way.
Oh my god, I'm going to change it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And then
oh my god, it's all coming together.
All right.
And then we flip this.
We've got to redraw this a little bit, but I can do it.
Okay, okay, look at this.
Pistol, there's a song to make everything come together.
Oh, wait, we gotta make sure.
There you go.
To make everything come together.
We gotta add the thong.
A thong, thong, thong, thong.
Okay, good.
Okay.
Oh, we can fix this.
Ooh, that's too...
Ooh, it's too high.
It's okay.
I can fix that.
Here we go.
This is the hardest part Guys This truly is the hardest part
And then
There we go Oh my god, we did it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait.
Did I get the finishing touches?
Oh.
And then...
I don't know if I could draw the ass right now.
Stop, please.
This is as good as we can get.
There we go.
We got the front.
The front is all that matters.
The back, um, you know, we tried.
We tried on the back.
You can just, yeah.
We tried on the back, but the front is perfect.
You got this.
Fine.
And he's like that, right?
It's fine.
This is fine.
What is that?
There we go.
Oh, my God.
Done.
bikini oh why wait i gotta check on dad
all right what do we know
all right we go
bikini oh wait tomato bikini Tomato.
Tomato.
Bikini.
Yes.
Tomato Bikini.
For anyone year round.
Casual wear.
Party.
I wish I could put it as all.
There we go.
Let's buy it.
Let's go.
I think it's not even a match the skin tone.
I don't even... I think I got this.
I'm pretty sure I got the skin tone.
It's a meetup for big time bite of 69 enthusiasts.
I'm pretty sure I got the raw skin tone.
Something on your mind yes i got a perfect gift for you but
i did buy it where is it where is it
it's closing i freaking do it i need to like see her color
before it's fine it's good enough it's good she didn't get a
tan on that part only I mean, if you look from here, it
looks the same If you look from here, it works, I guess
Okay, wait Let me change your clothes real quick
Okay, she needs to take off her socks
And then There we go Now it works there.
She's so sexy.
Everything works out.
Joki is staring at Joki.
Not creepy at all.
Oh, Joki is leaving.
I want to chat.
Sure.
Oh.
I promise I'm not gonna steal it, but what's your most
prized possession?
What is?
My most prized possession.
Oh, that's hard.
Oh.
What is my most prized possession?
Money.
The scuff is part of the peel.
It's perfect.
Pop plus merch.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Did I have dog shirts already in here?
I don't remember
A dog shirt Why no no I don't remember I don't not I don't
remember my dog shirt in here yet I know.
Why?
He's like, God, yes.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I know what my- I know what my- I know.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
I know what it is.
Fortnite V-Bucks.
V-B-U-C-K-S.
Okay, V-B-B-U-C-K-S.
There you go.
Fortnite V-B-B-B?
Oh, I get that.
If I had a Fortnite V-B-B-B, I'd probably build a whole
museum to house it.
That's right.
Imagine all those V-Bucks, guys.
Oh, V-B-U-C-K.
Alright.
Doki, you go meet.
Oh, there's a party at Doki's house.
Like, Doki needs help.
Are she hiccuping, too?
Here we are.
Me?
I see.
This is gonna take a lot of elbow grease.
Huh?
I just cleaned my elbows.
Yay, it's a Doki party.
Oh!
No!
I'm done!
I never knew Toki would fix me.
Ain't no party like a Toki party.
I think I'm falling in love with Toki.
It must be love.
This is love.
No, no.
I want to start dating Toki.
Self-love.
Let's go!
Oh no, Doki doesn't even know A word about You asked where
it is But not the cat Baturus and they give a super chat
Thank you, thank you The muse that live on your island Will
naturally develop feelings for each other And even begin
relationships Kids can become besties with kids And adults
can have romantic feelings Or even get married married to
adults.
They may need your advice and these matters, so be sure to
give them your best.
Oh, no.
Oh, she's posing.
Guys, they give the five gift and chips.
They can thank you.
She doesn't know what to do.
Oh.
Hey, Doki.
What is it?
I've got to warn you.
I'm a red light.
Green light master.
Want to play?
Sure.
Let's go.
I don't know how to do it Here we go Green light Red light
Oh my god It's so good I'm so proud of myself Green light
Red light No!
I'm so proud of myself
That's all right.
I got at least I got to see Hey, you can't win them all, but
you can get this as a consolation prize at least I got to At
least a box of no, I don't do sexy dokey.
I don't want a box of tissues from you sexy dokey I should
have drawn on the cheeks.
I could still draw the cheeks guys Maybe I'll do it off
stream when I can use a style.
I had held it Oh,
goodbye, Doki.
The ultimate knight.
This is Kenoli.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, meet Doki.
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Hey, Doki.
All right, Doki has met Doki.
And that's a twin-doodle-head steppel-head.
A banana can be in society.
Of course, Doki will be into them.
Seems like mine is.
Oh?
Oh, Groo.
What is it?
There you go.
I would just love it if it were a flower plant to ride.
Right here?
What the fuck are we going to do with...
I'm fine.
Fuck, you have so much money.
I might as well.
go build it yourself random ass place for a flower platter
thanks that'll make life on this island a million times
better yeah all right grue oh wait wait grue has never met
doki art me could i have a moment My name is Groove from
Despicable Me Movie.
Hey, Groove from Despicable Me Movie.
I'm Doki.
Okay, now they've met.
Now they're acquaintances.
A will-fell-cheap sort of person.
Sorry, I can't talk anymore.
I'm gonna fall asleep.
Oh, no!
Rejected!
Oh my god.
And then she just wants to talk to sexy Toki.
She doesn't want to talk to Groo.
Oh, Groo.
I'm sad.
Don't worry.
Hang out with your people.
They'll appreciate you.
Wait, you never met Toki?
Oh, he doesn't want to talk to anyone.
Oh.
I need a bit of help.
Oh, no.
He's in the funk now Because Doki rejected him He got
rejected by Doki
What are you doing?
Or does the bean nearly pale At the vast expanse of a sea
And I see they give us super chat They give everyone gift
and chips Thank you Oh wait let's Let's have Doki Dr. Doki.
Yeah, I love...
Oh.
Huh?
Do you need me?
You said...
You know?
Oh no, Doki doesn't know!
Doki is mine, sweetie!
Hold on, Doki doesn't know!
I love Doki!
Me too, I love Doki too!
Doki?
I love you.
Oh!
You know what?
I love Doki.
Alright, Doki.
Why don't you talk to Gru?
Maybe it'll help.
Doki is praising Gru for having the same look in his eyes as
Sam's Undertale.
Oh, he feels better now.
That's right.
Oh.
Look in him.
Look at her go.
Huh?
Yay!
Feels better!
Do that funky dance, Doki.
Vibes.
Nice.
Yeah, it's got the moves.
They're flunking it.
All right.
Are they met yet?
I love Doki.
Ta-da.
Good evening.
Kevin from the Minion Smoothie.
Fun fact about himself as an icebreaker.
Oh, okay.
Good for you.
Anything?
Oh, whoa.
I got a wishing fountain.
Snuggly, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yay, level 10!
What can I do?
Okay, I can do into...
Oh, island objects!
House exteriors.
House interiors.
Oh, I can decorate the house, right?
What is island?
I guess it's like decorations on the island itself.
I'm going to say...
Oh, level up.
New quirks!
Oh, eating style!
You know what?
I'll get...
I'll get that.
Eat...
Wow, it's cutely...
Oh, we'll get that.
We'll get the eating style.
Wait, are treasures pets?
I'll get a treasure.
I need to draw pets.
Oh, travel tickets!
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Island residents have long dreamed of traveling the world
And now their wish has come true Residents can now be given
the gift of travel By selecting travel tickets from the
wishing fountain At hearing the news, locals explain I can't
wait to finally take a vacation Yay!
We can fly now The first available trip is an oceania tour
I'm told a wish has already been added So someone can leave
immediately Check the wishing fountain to learn more Unlike
other wishes, it's possible to give the travel ticket
multiple times Granting wishes increases the number of
deaths Okay.
Why would you want to leave Doki Island?
You can have everything you want here.
Thanks for watching.
I don't understand.
We have everything you've always wanted.
On Doki Island.
Who deserves to go to Australia?
Guys, who do we give Australia to?
Of all the Doki's.
And Gru and Kevin.
Yeah, why do they want to leave me?
Gru?
Out of all the turkey.
Who do you want to send Gru?
We'll send Gru to Australia.
Alright, Gru, goodbye.
You're going to Australia, Gru?
Oh.
Are you really giving me an oceanity of Sometimes you go to
someone worse to truly appreciate the grassroot as you makes
them appreciate Doki Island more.
He brought Kevin.
He actually brought Kevin.
No way.
Look at that.
The Spokul me for.
It's going great, guys.
It's Caddus.
Welcome.
It's Australia's Great Bear, Yubi.
Say cheese.
So good, is she?
I got more sweaters for the day.
Say cheese.
The end.
I hope Rue and Kevin had a great time in Australia.
What does it look like if I save it?
What does it say?
Oh.
Oh, it doesn't say anything.
This was a wonderful trip.
Thanks so much for letting me take it.
Of course, crew.
You deserve it.
Yoki was so mean to you.
Oh, I got Kauaida plush.
Groo leveled up.
Alright, little quirks.
Oh, yeah, that should be Garfield's.
Alright, let's get the...
Which one fits Groo the most?
Oh, here, Sandworth hands folded.
Yes.
I don't...
Oh, wait, crossed.
Just like in the movie.
Take this.
Take this, Groo.
It's just like in the movies!
In your posters!
Oh, what are you thinking of?
You should definitely be friends with Doki.
What should we talk about?
Oh, I know.
Other.
Oh.
What did you have in mind?
The groove is an activity.
Being so sexy.
How does
that sound?
Being so sexy.
H, H, H, H, H, H, H, H.
Oh, it doesn't work.
God damn it.
What is this?
Being so sexy.
No.
Don't you what the hell?
Sexy don't you would appreciate it.
She would appreciate it.
Okay, we had to do stealing the moon, which is what he was.
Or being so sexy.
Ah.
I like this one.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about being so sexy.
Seconds too late.
Good evening, Doki.
Do you feel like talking about...
out being so sexy yeah sure but tell me grew from despicable
me movie how good are you at being so It works so good!
But I do think you'll find anyone on call not related to
other islands who's better at being so sexy off than me.
Oh, she's so impressed!
I don't respect folks who are good at being so sexy off!
Yes!
It works so good!
again it wakes up here see that's why i did it oh let me get
dad in here let me get dad in here
all right they're friends now this is the best game of all
time nice i knew being so sexy all would bring toky and me
together I hope Groove from Despicable Me movie shows me all
the tricks of the trick.
Oh, all the tricks on how to be even sexier.
Look at that.
I told you it'd work, guys.
I told you.
Oh, wait.
Face Clan.
What's going on to Face Clan House?
What are you dreaming about, Doki?
What's going on?
Yeah, what's going on?
Nothing.
Oh my god, that's scary.
No, not Guru.
I, Guru does not work with that face.
Such a strange dream.
Oh, I got a mirror.
All right, we gotta look at.
Apparently you guys said we can create a, we can create a
pet now.
New creation.
Treasures.
Yes.
okay all right i'll create a normal one an or
wait wait before i create dad before i create dad
i'll create dad soon guys dad will be the second one i
create we have to make this
Wait, I gotta look at a reference I gotta look
at And then, and then I'll create Dad And then I'll create
This first, though, this first This takes priority, guys
Okay, I need a darker I need a darker
Oh, no.
All right, I got it.
Oh, what?
Oh, my God.
I have to do it, like, in one?
Wait, what?
Oh, my God.
That's weird.
You have to do it in, like, one stroke for it.
Okay, now that I know that.
Fuck that shit.
layering that wait what does it not work on the layered
I don't know
who's pet this is gonna be it there'll be somebody's pet
There you go.
And then...
It's good enough.
It's close enough.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, let me move this to the right so I can add a backpack.
Okay.
Oh.
First try.
Okay.
Let's go.
We got him.
We got a pet, guys.
Wait, I can actually add shading to this.
Oh, my God.
Beautiful.
Wait, I can actually do more.
No, actually, let's just do this.
There we go.
Perfect.
Amagas.
God, what is that?
It's amagas.
A trait.
I'm mysterious.
Where is the floating?
Wait, how do I know it's...
Let me go that way.
Trotting?
It has to be trotting, right?
I wish I could...
Venting.
Oh my god, there's so many choices.
I don't know.
Venting.
Wait, what's six?
Wait.
Venting.
Okay.
Wait, Ed.
Venting.
buff that bad base which one is it all right which one nine
and then megaphone
out of ten out of ten or nine nine
or ten
not i see more tens all right i'm going with ten vent
venting here you go among us yay let's buy get a pet
oh okay don't have room anymore in the island i keep
forgetting to create space for
Alright, nice.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
A new store called My Treasures has opened on not related to
other islands.
Yay!
This store sells treasures that were crafted at a pallet
house workshop.
Residents are related, calling in to make cash register
sound effects and saying, what shimmering riches await us.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Doki, and you're up to date.
We're up to date now.
All right.
Welcome.
Let's buy Amogas.
Thank you very much.
Oh my god, he's only $5.
All right, who deserves him?
Guys, who should we give it to?
Sexy Doki.
Doki.
Okay.
Which Doki do we give it?
We have to give it to a Doki, guys.
The first Doki.
All right, let's give it to...
But then the first Doki can't have dad!
Looks like the season's hottest look is a tomato bikini.
It's so cute.
But then Doki can't have dad if we give...
If we give...
All right, let's help Kevin.
Okay, uh...
Oh, grab.
We got Doki feeling.
We need you to help Kevin.
Oh my god, wait.
She drew...
Oh my god, she's already in her head.
She's already in her head.
I just saw it.
I didn't realize she drew Doki.
What's the matter?
I just can't.
Have you tried not doing that?
No.
We'll give it a Doki Field.
Doki Field gets everything.
You're a real life saver.
I'm just happy I could help.
Or sexy Doki.
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's so many choices.
So many choices!
We'll give it to Doka Field.
Hello, Doki.
I got you a gift.
I made this just for you.
Look at him.
You gave her an Amagas.
Hey, take it out.
She really likes it.
Wait, take it out.
I want to see.
Oh.
Alright, let's give.
Oh, we had the eating.
This one.
Oh my god.
Which one?
Gusto or voraciously?
I'll fix the eyes later.
I'll fix the eyes behind the scenes that's true we'll do
gusto gusto all right eat
it's like the comic panelists i feel a little different how
so wait bring out bring it out why does he bring out the
gift bring it out how do i make it or walk Why aren't you
walking him?
I gotta wait.
Yay!
I gave you my magas.
Please respond.
Oh, there's an event!
It's celebrating me!
W.
You, W, W, W, W.
Island residents happiness levels.
Let's go live to the event.
Yay!
I'm covering up.
I'm covering up dokey.
Oh my god, it's all the dokeys too!
It's all the donkeys, too!
We give you our return.
I love how it's all the donkeys.
I got bronze trophy!
What a wonderful performance.
And a remarkable way to express appreciation for Dutch is 22
WWE, WWE, WWE, WWE, WWE, Double, he, double he.
It truly warms the heart.
Ungrieve from despicable me, Lugi.
Interrupted, date.
We did it.
We sure...
Oh, all right, walk your...
Well, after remembering urgent task, walk your dog.
Walk your amagas.
I'm going to wait until she walks him.
What is your important task?
Thank goodness.
everything away after all you have nothing thank goodness i
put everything away i've been thinking lately that dokey and
i could get to know each other better do you think dokey and
i would make a yes absolutely really well maybe there is
something there maybe they'll get a divorce later oh vibes
still vibing
All right.
Bring out.
Oh, oh, my God, dude.
Bending.
Look at it.
He's betting it.
He's
here.
Look at him, yo.
Look at him, look at him.
stupid oh my god look at him go he's prospecting of course
that's why he could only break him inside there's no fence
outside oh my god exactly that's so fucking stupid
here girl you go talk to Doki oh oh he's never interacted oh
Kevin oh I forgot to give him the kitchen good evening wait
let's see what he wants first I want to try living with
group oh my god it's not coming together yes we'd be
spending a lot of time yes what's something you think we
enjoy doing every day it's from Dispickably Movie and I Live
Together.
Oh.
Let's see.
It's canon.
Stealing the moon.
This is where it comes together.
My fan fiction is all coming together.
Stealing.
Oh my god, the movie script.
Oops.
Stealing the moon.
Yes, it's real.
I hate it.
I'll go talk to you.
It's becoming canon!
That movie is becoming canon, guys!
Hey, hey, hey, can we check for a moment?
What's up, Kevin from the minions movie?
Well, if the two of us live together, what's something you
think we enjoy doing every day?
Let's say it together on three, one, two, three.
three oh oh still in the mood he's into it look he's like
that's what i was actually thinking about
yay it worked
oh my god it's happening the speakable me for in production
this is gonna be a blast don't you think the houses here are
a little small I'm thinking we'll need to build a new one
all right who's the location where will they live together I
guess like here we'll put it here don't make me terraform
I'm sure we'll have a great time living in this house
together Say, do you have any ideas for what to call a
household?
Wait, what do they call their house?
I'd love to hear it.
Despicable me for it.
I got it.
Wait, four it already happened?
Okay, I've lost count.
I didn't know how many despicable me.
movies there are.
Despicable Me 5.
Here we go.
Then we shall be henceforth known as Despicable Me 5.
Thanks for the excellent idea.
I hope you'll keep- There's too many movies, yes.
We did it.
Um, I own a Swalovski Kevin.
Crystal.
You can't say I'm a fake fan.
That's right.
I own a Swahski Kevin Crystal.
Alright, time is up.
Minion Larver.
I feel like I got one step closer to my true self.
You know what?
You done?
Thanks for everything you done to make this island a
wonderful place.
Now it might be nice if the mees had a place to gather and
join me on chat.
a thing why don't we build it oh the restaurant yes that's
where all the drama oh my god this is a giant ass restaurant
where the do i build this
what the fuck okay we'll build it here
we interrupt to bring you some breaking news here's what's
happening on our island tomorrow a good serving
establishment known as a restaurant has opened on not
related to other islands this will be a great place for
people to get together for the purpose of talking with their
mouth full i can't wait to eat while staring at someone
else's face the whole time one resident said in a very
sarcastic tone thanks for watching yeah and you're up to
date you can grab me some ring them anytime it's this
perfect spot for me to get along chat oh okay what are you
bringing okay what the fuck where's joki doing
F.
Whoa!
Okay, let's bring...
Alright, let's bring...
Doki.
And...
Let's bring Doki.
Doki.
Oh, Doki's washing dishes.
Now, it's no...
It's not washing dishes time.
Doki.
Here's your order.
One item off this special menu.
A special split pea soup infused with popcorn shrimp.
Oh my god, that sounds fucking terrible, Doki.
The split pea soup infused with popcorn shrimp.
Just a ticket.
That sounds fucking terrible, Doki.
The aroma of the popcorn corn shrimp is out of this world
what the fuck what the fuck puts those two and two together
do not eat that special soup oh hey there's a gotcha pod all
right and then we'll bring jokey in let's see what happens
yeah you are Oh my gosh, she can't stop talking about
gambling.
She does not have a problem, guys.
And it's over heels.
Oh, Doki's getting friend zone, guys.
Oh, no.
Doki is getting friend zone by Doki.
All right, we got another wish, though.
Yay!
She's spilling her spaghetti.
let's see level up what else did it give us oh ballet okay
but i do want to get another oh i can't get another treasure
all right we'll just we'll save it for a bit i don't know
what to get for now all right and then we'll get doki here
too it's like the meeting of the dokeys
oh wait the other doki left hey there all right oh dokey
what is it dokey oh she's daydreaming try and catch me dokey
oh no he's so hungry he's taught i'm so hungry
i'm so hungry John.
Oh,
that's all she wants.
Just gotta get him the lasagna.
Oh, and then Despicable Me 5.
Oh, they're having a little cup of noodles.
You know what?
I think it's a good time to end it.
Oh my god, I've been fucking playing for four hours.
What an adventure.
We had two new villagers two new residents on Doki Island
that has been a wild wild ride I'm glad we finally got the
restaurant I heard a lot of things can happen in the
restaurant so wait the other Doki wait wait a minute okay
where is where is okay maybe Sexy Doki will hang out with
the other Doki's alright Sexy Doki get over there Retro Doki
bringing back 2010 trends haven't happened.
Jay.
But no!
Fudge, even the Super Chat, thank you.
Come over there.
Go meet the other Doki's.
Doki, come on!
Talk to them!
Nice to meet you.
I'm Doki.
Nice to meet you, Doki.
Hang out with them!
Then we'll get it on because they're about the same age.
Wow, it's crazy.
They're all about the same age.
Oh!
Oh, they all left.
Oh, oh.
No!
Sexy dough.
Oh, okay, nice.
Okay, see?
Doki is so friendly.
I was going to say, why do you guys all leave when Doki
came, huh?
All Doki should be treated equally.
Run Doki.
Oh, no, Doki's here.
We got to go.
Oh, yeah.
The whole three of Doki's were going to leave.
And all you think it was a super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to call you.
That was another fun day with Doki.
Doki, Doki, Doki, and Doki.
I'm going to go head off now tomorrow.
We're going to be playing MousePI.
It might be a long stream because it is, and I didn't have
to stream for it.
So I'm going to see if I can get trying.
It's apparent I just found out, like, last, on the last
stream that was a very long game.
So I'm going to see if I can make as much progress as I can.
But it was a fun stream.
Thank you.
for watching as always everybody stay high i can't believe
it despicable me five is writing itself right now as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you step for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
i have to walk dad too i think that's why he was like
barking earlier hey guys bye everyone bye